or Churchill who's a member of the
American Indian Movement an author of
many books including agents of
repression the fantasies of the master
race and the struggle for the land that
are published by South End press the
movie incident the incident at Iguala
has received a lot of fame a lot of
people have been seeing it can you tell
us about that movie and the principal
person involved well the principal
person involved is the subject of the
film is man named Leonard Peltier who
was sitting in a cage at Leavenworth
federal prison right now as a result of
being accused of having killed two FBI
agents who are in the process of
engaging in an armed invasion of the
Oglala Lakota or Pine Ridge Reservation
located as Russell Means would put it
between Nebraska and South Dakota
meaning it's on South Dakota Nebraska
line but he doesn't acknowledge being
part of either states an independent
nation in his view and by law should be
considered that way as well during the
1970s the American Indian Movement just
sometimes been referred to as a shock
troops of Indian sovereignty took a
stand on the Pine Ridge Reservation
under the provisions of the 1868 Fort
Laramie Treaty to insist upon the
exercise of Indian treaty rights there
to self-determination economic
self-sufficiency jurisdiction over their
own property and so on these are legal
points that are brought out in US as
well as international law that was such
a threatening concept of the federal
government the idea that its own law
would be enforced with regard to Indians
that had sent an essentially
counterinsurgency specialist from the
United States Army from the Pentagon
82nd Airborne Division and from Fort
Bragg and a number of
counterintelligence specialists from the
Federal Bureau of Investigation to mount
what in their internal documents they
refer to as a suppression of insurgents
they engaged in an exercise of
counterinsurgency within the borders of
the United States within the past 20
years counterinsurgency is not a law
enforcement technique I want to make
this clear it's not taught in police
academies has taught at the Special
Warfare school it is a technique that is
employed it's a doctorate in fact which
is taught at the War College and a set
of techniques employed by groups like
the Special Forces this
applied inside the United States are
people who were construed by the
government of the United States rightly
or wrongly and I would argue wrongly but
nonetheless they viewed the people who
were the targets of this as being
citizens the domestic citizenry of the
United States
they fought this out over three year
period time beginning in 1973 ending
sometime in mid 1976 primarily through
use of a surrogate surrogate
organization called goons guardians of
the Oglala nation which were commanded
controlled funded fact founded by
federal agencies primarily the FBI the
goons were equipped by the FBI with
automatic weapons armor-piercing
ammunition various explosive devices
they were provided with field
intelligence and so on by the FBI
to go out and neutralize nuts the term
they employed members of the opposition
American Indian Movement members and
American Indian Movement supporters
members of grassroots traditional
organizations above Nilo Lakotas in
order to end this drive towards treaty
rights and self-determination as a
consequence a minimum of 69 members and
supporters of aim died during that
period of time the FBI which exercised
primary jurisdiction on the reservation
during that period did nothing to
prevent it in fact made various awards
to surge of the participating members
number of these murders were witnessed
in each case where there were witnesses
the killers or the assailants were
identified as being members of this goon
squad which in effect functioned as a
death squad for purposes of imposing a
certain political control political
order upon the colonized people there
along about 1975 for the first time the
traditionals who are just getting
hammered by this there's the stating
casualties not just fatalities but
there's another 340 odd people who are
seriously physically assaulted on this
reservation it's only ten thousand
people you got a death rate there you
got a political violence right there
that is comparable to nothing in the
United States in the 20th century but is
rather comparable to the repression of
the left in Chile after the Pinochet
coup in which it Salvador Allende's
overthrown that level of violence not in
terms of the size of the pile of body
but
proportionate rate of which the violence
is occurring you got the traditionals
that are asking to provide them with
armed security the alternatives either
to abandon the political struggle or to
engage in armed security to prevent
armed assault this happens in a number
of places on Pine Ridge one of the
places that had happened was a location
called the jumping bull property it's
owned by a jumping bull family near
Ogallala a an emic security group called
Northwest aim headed by three people
Leonard Peltier Bob Robideau and Dino
Butler was provided there were about 88
members there to provide security to the
jumping bulls this becomes a point of
attack by the FBI there's a number of
stories are brought out to explain why a
pair of agents went in there two times
in two days in order to interact shall
we say with young people inside all of
which turned out to be false what
appears to have happened is that they
sent two agents Jack Koehler and Ron
Williams onto the jumping bolt property
under pretext of serving warrant on the
guy they knew wasn't there in order to
provoke an armed altercation with the
people who were inside who were expected
to be aid fighters
once the fighting broke out than they
expected to be reinforced by an
approximant
150 SWAT trained personnel that were pre
positioned in the immediate area and
they just roll up the end camp but they
would also have a sensational incident
that will allow the FBI to bring
extraordinary force to bear on the
reservation to finish this off once and
for all this little war they had going
because they hadn't been able to destroy
the movement they had not been able to
destroy the resistance despite the
degree of physical pain that had been
inflicted over preceding two and a half
years didn't work out there were about
thirty Indians there instead of eight
the two agents got cut off and they're
expected reinforcements they got killed
it's not known with any clarity outside
of the american indian movement who it
was that killed the agents it is known
within the indian movement who killed
the agents which is to say it is known
that an individual was i was referring
to earlier sitting in prison for that
act Leonard Peltier did not pull the
trigger that killed the age
it was involved in the firefight but he
was not the killer ultimately you have a
whole kind of show trial of the worthy
of Joe Stalin in the Soviet Union you
have essentially a showpiece trial a
kangaroo trial in order to put someone
in jail for this that someone ends up
being Leonard Peltier who was felt to be
by the people who tried him by the FBI
by the courts the significant figure in
the resistance and what they wanted to
symbolize was the kind of punishment the
consequences that would be inflicted on
anyone who resisted armed incursion by
the forces of the United States and
Indian country that these would be cost
prohibitive and ultimately no one would
want to do it Leonard Peltier therefore
symbolizes the ability of the federal
government to impose its will upon
oppressed people and get away with it
make it stick
conversely should we be able to get him
out of this cage that they put him in
for this act that he did not commit he
would symbolize our ability basically to
arrive at an opposite outcome to deny
them the prerogative to imposing their
will upon peoples at whim so it is
taking on a life and a meaning and a
dimension that the transience himself
and his individual case now that that's
what the movie is about that's the
context in what you do it occurred so
for years you've been coming out of free
Peltier campaign and has it had any
positive consequences do you see any
possibility that this might work that
you might actually either get another
trial and possibly be exonerated or
simply be freed well the stakes of this
are very high okay
partly because of the symbolic reasons
that I was talking about if he were to
emerge from the prison as a free man
that it would symbolize that the
government cannot sustain the kinds of
consequences it needs to sustain in
order to be able to without any
appreciable resistance at all visit
these kinds of horrific policies on
people year in year out generation in
generation out at this point century and
sense
so it would be a very negative symbol
from their point of view the other thing
is the way that the case has been
handled in the context in which this
occurred should he come out should there
be a breach in this this insistence that
the guilt is on the side opposite the
government then you open several lines
of potential criminal culpability for
people within us police and intelligence
agencies and in governmental positions
that run out and into fairly high levels
so they're not really comfortable with
that it also suggests major error in the
part of the US judiciary possible
collusion and complicity in a cover-up
the factual circumstances of a case the
leaving of a human being as a bonafide
uncontestable political prisoner perhaps
prisoner of war in a u.s. institution
something they've been told to do you
see the ramifications string out on the
other hand the 8th Circuit Court of
Appeals has acknowledged the fact that
the evidentiary chain by which he was
convicted of murder in the first place
no longer exists consequently he is not
validly incarcerated for murder he's
entitled to retrial prosecution has
argued that he was not convicted of
murder although that was their case that
was presented the evidentiary rulings at
trial follow the line of thinking that
he is being tried as a principle in the
closing argument of the prosecutor at
trial was that he in fact did it the 8th
Circuit Court as a result of that
concluded he was not in prison for
aiding and abetting in a murder either
he's not in prison for murder
well he's not validly so he's not in
prison as a result of having been tried
and convicted of aiding and abetting in
the murder the only question I didn't
answer is if that's the case what's he
in prison for there's a appeal going
before the court again oral arguments on
the 9th of November particularly on that
basis there's some other elements
involved but the focus is going to be
right there as a habeas corpus appeal
deliver the body if you can't explain
why you have the body locked up
basically the grant
the Supreme Court before disallowed
another trial courts the Ninth Circuit
on Pelt ears case twice without
explaining why okay the first appeal
there were 31 reversible errors found in
the record okay the head of the
three-judge panel the 8th Circuit Court
who heard the
first appeal decided nonetheless despite
the fact he had 31 potential
opportunities to reverse and send us
back to trial that he would not do so
the judges name rated the panel was
William Webster by the time the opinion
was read he had already left his
position in the eighth circuit to assume
directorship of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation of the 31 reversible
errors 19 involved FBI misconduct and
there was an obvious very high interest
in part of the FBI as an institution to
see a conviction in this case because it
involved the deaths of two of its agents
so you can sort of see where that one
went Supreme Court refused to review
that case the second appeal resulted
when I was talking about the
determination there was not a valid
murder conviction and that he had not
been convicted of aiding and abetting no
suggestion as to why he would be in
prison other than to reverse would take
a record which they acknowledged as
being fraught with FBI misconduct and
imputing further misconduct in the
bureau which the court was reluctant to
do so rather than impute misconduct to
an agency they already acknowledged had
exceeded the bounds of propriety
Authority and perhaps legality they left
a human being sitting in a prison cell a
maximum-security prison cell for no
appreciable reason at all we'll see what
happens the next time but on the last
time Supreme Court refused syrup refused
to review the case despite the fact that
one of the arguments the Eighth Circuit
had entered was that presented with
evidence that was now on the record a
jury might possibly have entered a
different verdict they maintained that
in order to reverse it was required that
they conclude that a jury would probably
have reached a different verdict this is
based on a Supreme Court case called
Bagley and the Ninth Circuit Court had
already determined that the possibility
of a different verdict was sufficient to
cause reversal so you got an inequitable
standard of application of law there
something which structurally requires
the Supreme Court clarification and they
refused to clarify their own case if
they had to review Peltier to do it so
that's our situation here there are
compelling reasons why I should say this
case will be
if there's any modicum of justice
involved in the American judicial system
but on the other hand the political
realities in the history of the case
strongly suggested - well not it's going
to take a good deal more expression of
popular outrage at the nature of justice
reflected in this case I think before
either politically or judicially or both
the United States is systemically moved
to do something about it
to effect justice and meanwhile Amnesty
International still has Leonard Peltier
as listed as one of America's political
prisoners as political prisoner but not
a prisoner of conscience if he was dead
he would be a prisoner of conscience
well he would be a victim of whatever it
was it caused him to be a person of
conscience I guess under amnesty rules
he cannot be adopted as a prisoner of
conscience because he had the audacity
to defend himself against armed attack
and apparently under the rubric cannot
do that and he's acknowledged that he
did in fact participate in the firefight
that he fired at the agents at the same
with the ACLU they won't get involved in
it because there was some type of armed
conflict involved well ACLU has managed
to become involved in several cases
involved armed conflict when they were
extreme right-wing organizations at
issue right they've done increasingly
that direction I won't draw it for the
conclusion to what that means but the
ACLU has to live with itself
Peltier on put this forward clearly is
not a good shot he fired from a distance
and acknowledged that his
acknowledgement of his participation is
simply an honest statement yes I fired
in self-defense he has said and it's
corroborated by everyone who was there
that he didn't hit anybody for simple
reason he was probably not capable of
hitting anyone who's firing wild every
time one of his co-defendants Bob Robert
on the other hand has stated quite
clearly on the record during his trial I
shot them both all right
the first rounds that went into each
agent went from a 44 magnum Ruger rifle
fired at distance as Robert testified I
was the only one with a 44 mag if the
initial ones were mortal wounds Bob
Robert who has an effect said I killed
them both
they would have been dead and he was
acquitted by a jury an all-white jury in
Cedar Rapids Iowa of any wrongdoing
based on the fact that he had reason to
fear for the safety of himself in the
safety of those around him given the
reign of terror which had been
objectively perpetrated by the FBI on
that reservation in prosecution of the
state of war that we were talking about
this is a very middle American jury
found Rob ado and his co-defendant Dena
Butler who both acknowledged having
fired at the agency and robber to of
having hit them mortally of any
wrongdoing no murder self-defense
this is a jury speaking this is a
federal case the same case for which
Peltier was subsequently tried you know
you have a jury of middle-american
rednecks if you will reach the
conclusion that no murders had occurred
self-defense and murder are mutually
exclusive propositions so if no murders
that occurred that was a jury
determination one has to ask the
question of why they took the Leonard
Peltier to trial at all